Luke and Jake here at the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel and we're here in Alaska
we're chopping a lot of wood making
shelters and eating great food you
having a good time bud yeah
[Music]
Hey Jake you doing good yeah
oh
you good yeah
yeah
hey Jacobs give me a high five I'm
impressed you snow shoot a long way bud
yeah
you didn't rest that much should we
start getting cam set up yep
really
here go like that
this one's heavy but
get all that snow off our bed all right
guys this is me and Jacob shelter for
the night I want to finish it up I want
to go ahead and put some walls on it and
get it all battened down because it's a
lot windier today so we're gonna be a
lot more exposed to the element well
finding dead trees a cut won't be a
problem about nine out of ten trees here
are dead already in the summertime this
place is a massive forest fire risk so
thinning out some of these dead trees
won't be a bad thing
that one
[Applause]
okay
how you doing Jake you getting cold
what's cold your hands yeah let me see
your glass
okay go
we're gonna stick him in Daddy's pocket
to get them warmed up we've got some
backup gloves
they are mittens one of your gloves dry
in my pocket when those feels better
then we can switch your gloves back if
you want
foreign
hey Jacob are you feeling a little cold
you want me to make a little bed for you
okay
we're gonna take off your snow shoes
I've taken my boys camping in some
pretty gnarly conditions and one thing
I've learned never skimp on the kids
sleeping bag because if all else fails
you can always put them in their
sleeping bag
Hey Jake you feeling better
you like your sleeping bag
your feet nice and toasty
like that you ready for some hot dogs
yeah
my mom's your mouse stick ready
all right
you're doing a good job with that Jake
you like your hot dog
yes
that's hard to beat a hot dog over a
campfire
you nice and toasty in your sleeping bag
you want me to get rid of the smoke
okay
I got Jacob fed and warm now I need to
go ahead and process all this wood
foreign
thing I wanted to change about this fort
after my last camp out was I want to
make this platform a little wider
foreign
nice little pile of Timber there
Jakey a little hungry
you know what this is
it's cookie dough that's what the
cookies look like before you put them in
the oven
[Music]
it's down a little bit
foreign
what do you think Jake is that pretty
cozy in there
like
how are we gonna cook
harder
whoa
bye
well I've been working like a dog from
sunrise to sunset but unfortunately
that's not a very long time here in
Alaska gotta bust out my lamps a little
bit ready too
I'll tell you these ice fishing sleds
make really good beds for little boys
you put them on a couple logs so they're
up off the ice just put a little foam
mat in the bottom of this thing
now that'll make a cozy little bed
tonight
you probably need a pillow huh
you want a little headlamp
[Music]
yes now first off they they are scared
of people because people kill wolves
don't you worry
slippers little camping booties to keep
your feet warm you can wear these in
your sleeping bag
yeah see no cold toes I think we should
build a fire don't you
oh wow this shelter just jumped like 20
degrees it is so warm in here
but I gotta keep this fire mellow I
don't want to melt my tarp
well me and Jake are sitting here around
the fire and we're having a conversation
about wolves what do you think about
wolves Jake scary you worried about any
wolves coming and getting us yeah did
Daddy tell you you're safe
do you believe Daddy
no the wolves are scared of people will
stay far away especially if you have a
campfire the biggest danger around here
is Moose but just give them enough space
and they'll leave you alone oh that fire
was roaring it was getting to be a bit
much in this shelter so I went ahead and
moved it outside and took some of the
coals and put them right here I'm gonna
go ahead and start cooking some dinner
all right as usual I got a little
something special prepared for dinner
we're gonna have some Philly cheesesteak
sandwiches this is gonna be good
foreign
huh
all right we're gonna get Jacob some
food hey Jacob
Jacob buddy
[Music]
oh we we lost you there bud you okay
how about a big sandwich
yeah that sounds good what do you think
of that
does that look good
off
I like this you like this Jake
yeah this is hitting the spot
I think I might need to have another one
of those
all right I got something a little
special for dessert here
oh look at that it's got strawberries
raspberries blackberries blueberries
cream
look at this
we got pie for you you want me to spoon
it into your mouth just because I love
you so much and you're so tired
well you like you like dad's booting pie
into your mouth
ah
yeah we don't we don't feed you pie in
bed at home do we is that good yeah
there's no point leaving but leftovers
right
oh that was good
oh
hold on I got you oh that was good
all right guys I'm gonna read Jacob some
stories my dad used to read to me and my
brother when we were out camping this is
a collection of true bear stories from
around Alaska some of these stories are
a little bit intense so I'm gonna try to
pick an age-appropriate one here the
bear then lunged at him and they
embraced in a death struggle the man
using his knife and the bear it's fangs
and Claws well we've had a good time
reading stories and eating whipped cream
but Jacob's falling asleep and I think
it's time for me to get my bed ready too
foreign
guys I'm pretty proud with the progress
I made on the shelter and I've got a lot
to do tomorrow so we're gonna have a
full day full day tomorrow but I better
get some sleep I'll see you guys in the
morning
well good morning it's about an hour
before Sunrise it's me and Jake are
doing well
it's a little cold in here but uh we're
gonna get a fire started get all nice
and toasty again
did you get attacked by wolves
all right Jake you want to get some
breakfast
we've got little uh raspberry strudels
and chocolate croissants
because we can
there you go
watch my fingers
I also got some chicken and apple uh
breakfast sausages here we're gonna cook
those up I also got a couple eggs here
we're gonna cook those by the fire stick
goes
right there
what
there we go
well listen I got a bit of building to
do today so I'm gonna go ahead and clean
this stuff up and uh then we're gonna
get to work
foreign
all right let's test it out
[Applause]
now I just need to do a little trim up I
need to make these edges nice and clean
make these logs all the same length
foreign
well not too shabby that is a sharp
looking shelter right there
yeah I'm proud of that yeah we pulled
the tarp over the top that thing will
get sealed up really good I'm pretty
happy with the progress we've made today
unfortunately I'm not going to get a
chance to camp in it tonight
because Jacob do you want to go home and
see Mama yeah yeah I got a little bit
left I want to do on the shelter so I
think I'll save that for my next camp
out
now one thing I've got to finish when I
get back is I gotta wall in this whole
backside
you good yeah you like it when you write
out in your sleeping bag
oh
foreign
for today but don't forget to click
subscribe we put out new videos every
Saturday morning and we'll be back to
camp and finish this shelter and if you
want to see my previous video where I
started this shelter I'll put a link to
that video in the video description
below alright guys see you later if you
like this video don't forget to check
out the outdoor Boys YouTube channel
where we have hundreds of videos just
like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning hit that
Bell button you'll get notifications
thanks for watching
[Music]